AI芯片市场
又杀出了一匹黑马
Cerebras Systems
在IPO的前夕
二级市场已经抢疯了
IPO定价区间节节上调
认购超20倍
潜在估值已经接近500亿美元
当所有AI芯片公司都在拼
谁能够把芯片做得更小
GPU做得更强的时候
这家公司走了一条
完全不同的路
它造的芯片
比脸都还要大
直接把整片晶圆
拿来当芯片用
Cerebras的核心产品WSE
是史上最大芯片
最新版本集成了
4万亿个晶体管
90万个AI核心
这种模式能够几乎消灭
芯片之间的数据通信延迟
目前它的推理速度
比英伟达B200快28倍
也被视为少数有机会挑战
英伟达算力体系的公司之一
最近 Cerebras接连拿下大单
Meta率先采用其芯片
运行Llama 4模型推理
今年年初
OpenAI又签下多年算力采购协议
合同总额高达200亿美元
接着AWS也宣布
将其芯片引入云平台
Cerebras营收
三年增长近20倍
从“另类AI芯片创业公司”
逐步进入到
全球主流AI基础设施体系
Cerebras的这个路线
今天听起来很有想象力
但它曾经被认为是硅谷最疯狂
最不可能实现的项目之一
它在AI芯片周期里面
经历了三个“生死阶段”
整片晶圆这条路
意味着
更高的制造难度
更低的良率
以及超高的制造成本
德州仪器、ITT等公司都尝试过
但最后
都以失败告终
一度被业界认为是
不可能完成的任务
而Cerebras用了四年的时间
攻克了一系列的工程难题
最终在2019年
发布了第一代的WSE
产品虽然有了
但是市场却开始不买单了
随着英伟达CUDA生态
开始全面统治AI世界
AI芯片创业公司
集体遭遇资本退潮
SambaNova
Habana等大量公司
或是倒下
或是被边缘化
而Cerebras也一度运营困难
2021年
与阿联酋科技集团G42的合作
成为了Cerebras的“救命稻草”
紧接着ChatGPT的出现
也带来了新的转机
Cerebras的定位开始转向
"实时推理基础设施"
2024年9月
Cerebras首次提交IPO申请
但是由于G42的单一营收
占比过大而遭到审查
最终 在2025年10月被迫撤回
随着AI算力战争全面开启
瓶颈从算力本身
转向推理速度与响应延迟
过去被认为
过于激进的Cerebras架构
反而开始显现优势
市场开始寻找
“英伟达之外”的第二方案
Cerebras借机
转向AI云和超算服务
接连拿下OpenAI
等大型客户
与此同时
Cerebras又再次提交了IPO
不过 Cerebras的客户
依然高度集中
2025年阿联酋两家关联客户G42
与MBZUAI
合计仍然贡献86%的营收
当然 我们也看到
Cerebas近期在非常积极地
拓展美国本土的大客户
关于这家公司的技术路线
产品以及资本运作
我们之后
也会出一期关于Cerebras
更深入的视频分析
欢迎大家关注硅谷101